this game is called integer noughts and
crosses in fact you might like to write
up the time you might like to write off
the crop off the top of your page into
jar noughts and crosses so this is the
name of the game okay now you've all
played noughts and crosses before
there's going to be someone who has the
knot and someone who has the crosses but
this game has rather a few twists to it
okay first twist noughts and crosses you
usually need three in a row for integer
noughts and crosses you need five in a
row okay second twist each turn this is
why you need 5 not 3x turn you get to
put either if you're the Nauts player
two naughts down at a time or if you got
two crosses player two crosses at a time
okay here's the way it works silently
and what you decide who's the Nauts plan
who's the crosses player and I want each
of you I want each player to randomly
select a number from 1 to 10 doesn't
have to be the same number I'm going to
write down a start number for both of
these people because I have to play both
sides of the front here ok so I'm going
to go with three and nine okay three and
nine okay you can pick any numbers you
like so remember I told you each turn if
you're the not spread across the square
you put two things down right here's how
it works just follow how I play first
okay so i'm going to be the crosses
player first okay now remember i picked
this dis three randomly okay so the
first number i write down is whatever
number i had before three and then you
get to choose an operation based on the
numbers that are up there so here's what
I want to do I want to get things in a
row right so I'm going to go with a 3-2
equals 1 the two number two numbers i
chose with two and one so I see there's
a two and or one there now you see what
I've done okay it's the other players
turn watch carefully they've got a nine
so I'm going to go nine I want to block
that guy I'm gonna go nine take away 7
equals two so I'm going to put a 7 and
too now it's the other guys turn ok now
it's a new round so I start I start with
the number i ended with and then i say
yeah okay you want to block me over
there i'll try and block you over there
i'm going to go five and six bam bam you
see what he's doing ok alright so now
it's ok now I've got a two that's the
number i ended weird and I'd better stop
him right so I'm going to add negative 3
I have to I have to because otherwise
I'm stuffed ok what's two plus negative
3 2 plus negative 3 is negative 1 i'm
pretty sure oh that's convenient either
take that guy you're multiplying 2 plus
negative 3 if you want to think and this
is why your book might be helpful ok
here's my number line 0 1 2 here's where
i start if i add negative 3 i'm going 1
2 3 2 negative 1 so the goal is five in
a row you've got two boards there good
luck your time stop now